-Hey!
Oh, you look great.
-Hi!
You look great, too.
-Thank you so much for coming --
Oh, thank you very much.
Please.
For coming back
to "The Tonight Show."
It's so nice to see you.
I want to see you in person.
How's your quarantine
experience been, overall?
-You know,
when quarantine started,
I was like, "This is it."
I was made for this life.
-Wow.
-I didn't have to make up
excuses to not go to things.
You know, I'm like --
And I got to spend all this time
with my dogs,
and then after about two weeks,
I was like, "Oh,
I wasn't made for this life."
-[ Laughs ]
-I actually need
human connection.
And it made me realize
I need to call my mom more.
I need to check in
with my friends more,
not just check their Instagram
and be like,
"Oh, they're on a beach.
They seem fine."
-[ Laughs ]
It's like, "Really call them..."
-Call them and talk to people.
-...and say, "How are you?"
I found it to be
a great bonding experience.
I'm closer
to all of my friends now.
I'm closer with everyone
in my life,
and I am so blessed for that.
-You were finally, recently,
able to get back to work.
You just finished filming
a movie with Morgan Freeman.
How did it feel
to get back on set?
Was it --
Were you rusty?
Was it like --
just like riding a bike?
-I -- There was that moment
where I was like,
"Do I even know
how to act anymore?"
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-But I got there,
and it was such a perfect film
to transition
back into working again after
not really talking to people
for so long and
not having that kind of
connection and being on set.
-Speaking of Morgan Freeman,
you got to take away
a little souvenir of sorts
from Morgan.
Can you tell us about that?
And, by the way,
I'm already jealous,
'cause I know what it is.
-Yeah. Like, so I'm working
with Morgan Freeman.
He's one of my idols.
He's an amazing actor.
He's on that list of people
you want to work with --
right? -- as an actor.
And it was an amazing time,
but I did --
I couldn't stop myself
from asking him
to record my voicemail.
So now when people call me,
they get to hear Morgan Freeman.
-And you are the coolest 'cause
you sent us the recording.
Let's listen to this.
-You've reached Ruby Rose.
Leave a number.
Maybe she'll call you back.
[ Both laugh ]
-"Maybe"?
Maybe she'll call you back.
-Maybe she'll call you back.
Oh, my --
That's --
That's it
for the rest of your life.
-That's it.
It will never change.
-No. Why should it change?
That's unbelievable.
That is -- I love that
you brought it to us.
Thank you so much.
And good on Morgan Freeman
for being a good sport.
You know,
the last time you were here,
you were here to promote
the first season of "Batwoman,"
and we were both excited.
You were Batwoman,
the first one.
And we were freaking out, but
now you're not Batwoman anymore.
You -- What happened?
Why did you leave
after one season?
-Well, I didn't just leave.
I didn't up and leave.
We were in such a weird position
because we had to shut down
before we could finish
the season, because of COVID,
and then we went into lockdown.
And there was a lot of,
like I said earlier,
with reflection and things like
in quarantine and thinking,
and I ended talking
to Warner Brothers and Greg
and where the show was going,
and we really just kind of
had a really honest,
good chat where we sort of
mutually agreed that Kate Kane
and her story and everything,
we had done
what we set out to do.
We achieved --
I'm so proud of what we did.
I had so much fun.
I mean, you know,
I cried on your show
because of how excited I was.
-You were great.
-And I had a blast.
And I do really feel like
it was right for the show
to pass the mantle on
to someone else now.
There's gonna be
many iterations of Batwoman,
and I'm really proud of it, and
I can't wait to watch season 2.
-Oh, good.
That's good to hear.
Well, you crushed on it.
And it probably was good
training for "The Doorman,"
because, man,
you kicked butt in this film.
You shot this film in Romania.
Did you go to -- Did you see
Dracula's castle at all?
-Okay, yes. But here's the thing
about Dracula's castle.
People told me
it was Romania's Disneyland.
So I'm like, "Let's do this."
And when I get there,
there's all these merch stands,
and I had friends that were
like, "Send me back something
from Dracula's castle,
T-shirts, whatever."
I buy out everything.
Then I put the T-shirt on,
it's like Dracula, you know.
And I go in and I get
a major history lesson
that this has got
nothing to do with Dracula.
Like, this is just 'cause
it looks like --
it's the only castle that fits
the description from the book,
so they just kind of
made it a thing.
And I go in and find out this
place was Vlad the Impaler,
this horrible ruler
who did brutal war crimes,
and he actually would like
to impale people
and leave them around the city
and outside the building.
I'm in there thinking,
"Is this the right thing
to send home to my family?"
-[ Laughs ]
No, you can't do that.
You can't --
No, you can't buy --
You can't wear that T-shirt.
No, you got to --
-You can't.
This would be like --
If it's Disney Land,
it'd be like if Mickey Mouse
secretly loved hunting people.
-[ Laughs ]
-And, like, I haven't seen
Minnie Mouse in a while.
Have you?
-Okay, yeah, yeah.
-I haven't here in a hot second.
-That's interesting, you know?
That's interesting.
Yeah, you don't really
want the merch for that.
Yeah, you don't think
about that at all.
"The Doorman,"
Let's talk about your movie.
it's an action thriller.
It's fun.
Tell everyone what it's about.
-Basically it's about Ali,
who's the character that I play.
She is an ex-Marine,
and she goes through
a very traumatic experience
at the beginning of the film,
and she ends up moving back to
New York to restart her life,
heal, and try to get, you know,
herself back on track.
And she ends up getting a job
as a doorman,
which seems like a reasonable,
easy enough job
to go back into the workplace.
Unfortunately, she does end up
being at the wrong place
at the wrong time.
They end up shutting down
the place that she's working,
the building, to renovate,
and it actually doubles
as, really, a robbery, headed by
the one and only Jean Reno.
And she's there and left
protecting the very few people
that stayed during
the renovation shutdown.
And she ends up having
to go from being a doorman
straight back into being
the trained person
that she was and saving the day,
or trying to.
-I want to show a clip.
Here's Ruby Rose
in "The Doorman."
Take a look.
-Why would a decorated officer
hole up here as a doorman?
-To meet interesting people
like you.
-I had a friend
that came back after war,
and he was damaged.
Are you damaged...Sergeant?
-[ Chuckles ]
Not as damaged as you.
-What about this --
Unh!
Ohh!
[ Grunting ]
-Get their guns!
Take the gun.
Max, give me the rifle.
Find a way out.
You go that way!
-Ruby Rose, thanks again
for coming on the show.
Hope to see you again.
Stay safe, please.
Ruby Rose, everybody.